hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm not at my
home today I'm staying at a friend's
place in San Diego cuz Comic Con is
going on I'm gonna be introducing a film
called circle gonna be talking to the
audience getting some you know instant
feedback and also I'm gonna be hosting
the Q&A for the film so I'm down here in
SD right now staying at a friend's place
before I go to the movie in just a
little bit I wanted to check out Conan
hits Comic Con nad max-style
I wanted to check this out ASAP and I
was like [ __ ] it let's get the camera
set up let's do this
Oh Andy hey corn I'm heading down to San
Diego to Comic Con now are you ready
sure
you gonna take the train no you know
it's only a little over two hours so I
thought I'd Drive you know listen to
some tunes on the way down driving
sounds fun can I tag along of course are
you ready now yeah let's go to Comic Con
let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
PFF
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's pretty good relax
I don't know where we got lost can't see
it I'm coming down
scream leap a scarecrow many yeah we're
off the five we passed Saint Clemente
we're not on you shouldn't hit La Jolla
by now you know well the thing is is the
guitar so loud I can't hear the GPS I'm
sorry I get tired of it I know I know
but it's okay
hit me up before we go oh
[Applause]
yeah
once that's really in play can you hear
from Sam
go it's cozening
[Applause]
[Music]
check those inner result
basically
Andy Richter
now
here he is
oh [ __ ] it should have got a ticket
like right down the street
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
shucks
laughs again
olden olden Lassie
hey my god
welcome to comic-con
oh wow I really wish I was part of that
crowd yeah I'm at comic-con and I'm
probably never gonna see Conan but he is
seriously one of my heroes
you know I ever comment the other day
that it was like Ryan listen I know
you're like Conan but you're wrong he's
not funny I didn't realize that there's
a right and wrong to what you find funny
into it you don't find funny
that's just your own [ __ ] opinion I
like Conan I think he's [ __ ] hilarious
no seriously like I'm when I was in I
always linked it back to when I was in
eighth grade I started watching him when
I was in seventh grade I was going
through a lot of tough [ __ ] back then
growing up it was a little bit rough
Conan with something that was very
consistent in my life that constantly
cheered me up you know I won funniest
kid in middle school and I know a lot of
my humor has been inspired by Conan
especially the way he interacts with
people so yeah this is [ __ ] exciting
I hope some way I get at least shake his
hand about this comic-con intervention I
hope somehow I get to shake this guy's
anthro at Comic Con convention yeah I
just love to be on the show one day I'll
be cool
Conan if you're watching this love to be
on the show one day see what this tongue
can do huh sorry baby
anyway guys for you to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine because if we get
enough followers we can get product
placement even more product placement
for things such as candles candles are
great they light up the room they create
good illumination and also if you're
gonna have sex a time it's good to light
a few candles and you know what's really
hot sometimes Veronica does this she'll
let you light a candle and then she'll
start pouring the wax on my left nut
stings but man is
then she'll slap me call me a [ __ ] and
she'll say I'm hers put on that strap-on
[ __ ] me hard she's nasty she's nasty
Iraq candles